like I know comics they go to the same
therapist as me I was in the waiting
room the other day and I actually heard
my therapist laugh through the door and
I was like oh I gotta bring it again
this week
depression text online the other day
which i think means I have it but
watching porn
I cut then I'm the type of Jew that if
you don't like Jewish people I'm not the
one that's gonna turn things around for
you I saw a baby in the coffee shop the
other day he was wearing a t-shirt that
said I loved life I was like you'll grow
out of it I like baby you know what's
better than a baby by a little is not
having a baby most people I know they
look at sex like buying a car be like
can I see myself in this long-term most
guys know they look at sex like Park in
a car we're like there's a spot there's
another spot oh I have to pay money
we can't hope no one sees this
you